full of this child
this uh child-like energy yeah and
youthfulness and that you can see that
from his bedroom can't you i mean it's
like
i was just thinking like oh the joys are
having like a such an innocent bedroom
just chest trophies and chest things
it's like it's nice to see isn't it you
know it's all chess all chess last year
there was even a spider-man thing it was
a poster or something
so he sacrificed spider-man for more
chess
trophies for spider-man
meanwhile no queens can be declined
instead it's a variation of the closed
sicilian it's the bishop b5 czech
sicilian
that means that white doesn't open
things up in the center yet instead just
takes maybe a slower approach and eric
he's been doing this for years for sure
this position isn't new to him so it's
slightly surprising that he's thinking
maybe he's just trying to choose a line
that mishra will not be so familiar with
for example white can castle his king
away to safety here or i can push a
couple of different pawns forward
lots and lots of choice white's bishop
the one that has developed can just take
a step back another very fashionable
move but eric
with his time trouble issues maybe he
should be moving quicker at this moment
mishra looks very very confident very
well prepared
and uh
okay what do you think of this opening
choice by eric is this a good one
against younger player simon
yeah i mean i i think it's fine i mean
he
eric i i feel is the kind of player who
loves
tactics as much as anything else so i'd
love to have seen an open sicilian but
when you're playing a younger player it
is maybe good to play something not as
theoretical and the line that eric's
chosen here is is not one of the more
theoretical lines at least still gives
white some chances of an advantage but
uh i mean i've seen him play this type
of position many times over the tour i
mean it's quite actually rare that we
see someone have a repertoire and just
stick to it very fixed eric's repertoire
yeah and normally we see players you
know even though they've done a
chessboard course here and there they
that they're varying they will play the
maiden night off they'll play french
they will play e4 uh they'll push with
kingsport queenspawn and eric
what i like about it is that if you want
to
adopt this opening you can actually
follow eric's games
there there would be a good
role
one of the biggest mistakes i see uh
sort of lower rate of players play i
mean this is all theory so far on board
or do
maybe people watching this is they see
the top players they see the top players
playing so many different openings and
they try to copy that approach they're
like all right magnus is playing
different opening every game i should be
doing that as well
and i think this is just a wrong thing
to do i think if you're lower rated you
should probably stick to a much smaller
range of openings and get used to them
before you try to experiment with loads
of different kind of
variations because it's so hard to well
chesapore of course tells you the
opening moves it will drill that into
you but then what you do in the middle
game what are your plans what are your
opponents plans what are you trying to
do
and if you play lots of different
openings it's very hard to understand
what the plans are in the middle game if
you play only a couple of openings you
can master those plans a lot better so
it's just something to bear in mind
don't always copy what the top players
play even yeah i mean i mean one of the
things that i i always suggest is when
you're kind of learning an opening you
choose someone like eric who is
regularly playing that opening has
developed their system and you study
their games and once you've mastered the
little nuances then you can kind of move
on to other openings with a similar type
of
pawn structure maybe the same kind of
patterns
that's my always my advice and
what's kind of really
appropriate to our quiz of the day where
we're asking what are the things that
you struggle the most with in openings
and
what the players are pausing nikki h
says this is not a struggle that simon
will be able to understand but it's his
main struggle is not playing harry to h4
or the h5 square in every opening
yeah i mean
you gotta do that at some point nikki
you have to make the commitment
what do you think david i mean
yeah when in doubt push the age point
right yeah i don't think that's a sin i
think there's uh
problems to have eric could even do it
here couldn't he i mean it's like maybe
that's what eric's thinking about yeah
yeah
and uh i also
mad register forever says uh whenever
they face an opponent who plays the
queen's pawn opening i'm absolutely
confused how to play especially when i'm
black
yeah that's uh also a common kind of
story between us all we all
we like for instance if someone plays
the kings or pawn opening i'm always
like yeah kara khan not even a question
about that one but queen's born a little
bit more choice a little bit more
difficulty
different type of position
so yeah and again i would recommend just
just kind of take a decision you know do
you like closed positions do you like
open positions do you like to play
schematic in a schematic way which is
basically do you like to follow formulas
if so you know choose your opening
according to that i think madridista
forever that should be trying to uh win
that chessboard course on the queen's
gambit declined i mean it's a great way
to learn to play against the queen's
pawn it's solid it can take you up for
several levels and um yeah another thing
just choose a favorite player try and uh
learn what they do but uh i also like
simon's strategy there it's the whole
kind of jack of all trades master of
none thing just specialize in one
opening just become a master of that
opening no matter what the level as long
as you know the uh kind of ideas inside
out i don't think it matters what
opening really i mean people's people
are always arguing again it's that
opening snobbery thing they're saying oh
this opening is much better than that
opening and you know you even see it you
know a lot in the chat there i say
there's some people like oh yeah that
opens just rubbish you can't do that at
top level no one does that you know but
it's like yeah but if you're like 1000
rated it doesn't matter you know maybe
if you're 2800 it matters a bit but
there's a lot of snobbery any opening's
okay pretty much as long you know it
within the realms of like sensibility
yeah trust your instincts if you're
attracted to an opening it's for a
reason normally it's because it suits
your style uh it suits your kind of
temperament so if you're attracted to a
really attacking opening it means you're
probably an attacking player just follow
that learn the attacking ideas learn the
patterns learn how your opponent tries
to defend and
you need to learn one for white and one
for black correct that's the thing yeah
and for black normally maybe one against
the king's pawn one against the queen's
pawn from there you can
then you can start thinking what to do
against the english opening which is a
bit more rare or other things but yeah
focus one opening for white that's all
you need one opening for black against
king spawn or queens porn okay there are
some openings you can even play against
both the king's porn and queensborough
openings uh so yeah i did guarantee
everyone at the start of the show that
if you follow the show for the chestable
monsters you will become better at chess
and here you have a perfect uh
advice on how to get better at the
opening because the opening can be the
most frustrating part if you ask me all
the pieces on the board
so many possible moves it's very
confusing yeah no i i just i got a
little bit excited because you know i
was looking at this position and
checking it out on my database and you
can see that uh abby manuel is kind of
thinking he's thinking what to do next
and i've seen so
many tweets about this particular
situation which is
what happens
when your opponent doesn't play into
your preparation because so far this
particular game has been following eric
hansen's game against anish giri in the
air things masters and there of course
eric played something totally different
he pushed annie the a pawn one square
forward
and this move very rare
and now we're seeing abby manu
just going into the think tank and how
is he going to take advantage of this
move is he going to maybe just continue
as normal develop a rook put it on an
open line is he going to do something
concrete and maybe attack the knight or
something else
yeah and uh i think the mindset to have
is firstly ask yourself if you haven't
seen this move before why haven't you
seen it before is it because it's not a
great move by the opponent is it because
it doesn't really do much for the
opponent but if there's a specific idea
you think your opponent is going for
then you can look for the solution and
maybe if we jump into this exact
position we can talk about uh what's
been happening over the first
12 or so moves white has established a
really nice pawn center we saw a video
earlier um the howl's how-to of uh
occupying the center with pawns and then
kind of supporting those pawns with
pieces here eric has done everything
right according to traditional opening
wisdom but black has decent bishops too
black's bishops are kind of indirectly
pointing at the center
they have potential long term also
white's knight on the square can get
kicked away and that's why maybe um
ivanka mentioned eric in that game had
already pushed a pawn forward just to
stop this idea from black and okay he
doesn't go for this but it would have
been very tempting to me to kick away
this knight from his dream out uh kind
of dream post here which supports the
center at least kick it to the edge of
the board and from here maybe it could
be a target instead mishra though he
doesn't kind of take advantage of the
fact white has kind of saved on this
move he doesn't push his own pawn
forward he just develops his queen and
now we see eric
do something very similar to what he did
against anushkiri in that game a couple
of months ago just line his queen and
bishop uh queen and bishop up against
these pawns and uh later on maybe he'll
try and force a decision from black's
stronghold on this side of the board
meanwhile i think mishra needs to
activate these rooks very very quickly
and then he needs to strike at white
center you can't like let these pawns
kind of sit there controlling everything
for too long
yeah any preferences whose position
there was one thing that i was a little
bit baffled by and that was
abby manu putting his queen on the open
diagonal open diagonal open line that's
what i wanted to say and i was expecting
a rook to go there yeah i mean the queen
perhaps could be a little bit vulnerable
yeah i thought it might be trying to
move it around
the ankles so the rook comes and the
queen goes
sort of into the corner should we say so
uh it's quite hard to explain but
just to show a few moves on the board
david's saving me there put the queen on
this diagonal
this is quite a common plan it looks a
bit strange to put a queen in the corner
of the board but uh kind of from afar
she's a great long-range piece so she
supports her bishop on this diagonal
that's maybe one idea but
um yeah we'll find out if that's abu
mishra's
emmanuel mishra's plan uh long term this
is the current position and he's
definitely going to start bringing his
rooks towards the center
in general i agree with ivanka it's not
a great idea to place a piece on a
square you're not 100 sure about it's
best for example um if we just backtrack
this rook is nearly definitely destined
for this square so you might as well put
that put it there first and then keep
your queen more flexible maybe the queen
wants to kind of park herself on the
edge of the board
maybe she wants to come to this square
but once you commit her you're a bit
stuck and uh okay if we fast forward to
the current position as your banker
mentions once the white bishop moves out
the way she will become a bit of a
target so
um yeah still in the balance i'm
expecting eric in the current position
either to move his bishop out the way or
to make a decision with these pawns with
this pawn maybe to step it one square
forward or if he's feeling extra brave
to push it two squares oh wow i've
noticed one thing they've done with
mishra that like
he seems like a lovely kid but
they used the photo was maybe the
angriest photo
i don't know if you saw that but they
had all these other love they had all
the players lined up and they were all
like smiling and then mishra i was like
oh like he's gonna kill you and it's
like they just picked him but now i'm
just saying they've got a lovely a
lovely picture of him now so good work
there and i actually know that picture
as well is the one used on
his chestable course right
a young kid he actually has a chestable
course
i'm not sure is the following sort of
his games towards becoming
grass and how he became a grand master
and of course abby manu mishra is
actually like a huge adherent of
chesapeal you know in his run-up and his
journey to break those records he was
training on chassis ball for a
ridiculous amount of hours crazy i think
he had the yeah what is the chestnut
streak first of all to anyone new to
chassis ball
um it's basically when you practice the
openings um what chessboard does which
is kind of unique uh it allows you to
train it and it scores you so you have
to repeat the moves that it shows you
you have to get the moves right move
repetition it's about getting the move
repetition correct and just logging in
and practicing in that interactive way
something which they've done which no
other company has really done so just
that interactive thing the streak is you
just have to keep practicing keep
repeating you've also been very into
that your anchor right yeah i i i for a
period i know you were very good at
keeping your streak up yeah i had 100
days and then one day there was like
some problem with the internet and then
i couldn't get on to just the streak
then so you just have to log in for 100
days on a road yeah you have to log in
and you have well i was actually like
memorizing everything so i was working
super hard you know every day i would do
one hour on chassis ball i was doing
this for 100 days and then one day i
logged on and i was like
what's happening what's happening
and i had i didn't have the because you
can have also you can buy little rubies
but yeah and one of them is like to
preserve your streak
and i didn't have that one and i knew i
didn't have it and every time i tried to
log on it wouldn't let me and i was like
no
and then yeah and then that happened
yeah and i was like oh dear i have to
start again and then i built it up up to
another maybe 30 days but then i had
some tournaments and life got very busy
and what a great way to motivate
yourself to do the work and it's so
interesting to hear these young players
actually using
chesable for their work to become
grandmasters to to stay
at the top level like we know abhimanyu
mishra is doing in what has he been up
to over the last year so he became the
youngest grandmaster
ever last summer
what has happened since then he's been
playing a lot and doing very very well
really yeah there was one tournament for
example in st louis that he played in i
think most of the players were
grandmasters and he stormed a victory i
think he won seven out of his nine games
there wow yeah he was crushing grand
masters it wasn't just winning it was
just destroying them in style and uh
um i know he's been doing other things
school and life gets in the way and um i
mean he's still so young that he's got
so many things going on but he's been
playing and it's been going yeah i mean
very steadily upward
for him so
um of course we know his name now we'll
be hearing it for years to come but i
think in maybe three or four years he'll
be in the same position maybe the prague
is in where he's breaking into the elite
slowly and
whatever he's doing he's doing it right
and he seems to have a good support
network around him yeah and an
interesting fact about pragnanda is
during our chess talks he told me that
he had to dash off and he couldn't do
any sightseeing in oslo because he was
doing school and he was taking school
exams
and
i i think i read somewhere that he's
actually taking school exams right now
during this tournament as well as uh
playing in this tournament
he said he couldn't miss the opportunity
of testing himself against the best so
around the chest he's uh taking exams
yeah impressive oh wow
impressive guys these uh these chess
players oh wow yeah at 16 i had more
than enough to just get to school and
then maybe playing some football on the
side i was not competing with the best
in the world impress these guys are so
impressive and here he is playing
against eric hanson
a bar slightly roughly to the middle
and uh
i'll be money he's played fast in this
game is he learning from losing on time
basically in that previous game i i
think so and also this is very much
still in the realms of opening
preparation i mean he would have seen
that eric has played this system many
times and so you can just see by the
speed which he's now played that he
feels a lot more comfortable with the
position and it's back to business and
eric
is just uh he knows what he has to do
but he's just trying to think of ways
that he can psychologically outwit his
young opponent i mean i don't want to be
harsh to eric hanson and i just love the
way he approaches openings i like his
style especially with white pieces but
what has he been thinking about i mean i
do this quite a lot myself but it's in
positions that i'm trying to work trying
to calculate no but i'm trying to figure
out new ideas he's had basically this
exact position before this cost him half
his time that's like i remember when
someone goes i don't mean to insult you
but yeah it's always the way but you're
totally right yeah it's like whenever
he he he's got to move quicker what's he
doing it's really strange and also
white's last two moves have just been to
push pawns at the edge of the board not
really improving the position and that
has allowed
mishra the time to jump into white's
half of the board now with one of the
black knights and
now eric is finally starting to answer
serious questions but he's lost half his
time in the process i mean as ivanka
mentioned he had that position against
anish giri it was almost identical to
this position maybe just one small
difference
and
yeah
speaking to eric after the last major
tour
where he was a little bit disappointed
but he was playing the world's best
players it was played here live it
wasn't that long ago and he said well
you know we're having just informal chat
and he was like well you know i think
i'm playing well
except it's the openings and i need to
go away and practice my openings this is
like i need to the only one going to
compete with these players is to improve
and work just on my openings because i'm
getting worse positions you're playing
these guys i can't i can't get back into
the game so
it's kind of like it's a bit surprising
to hear see him play those same openings
that he was playing in the last tour you
know you'd hope that he'd done a bit of
work and maybe he has some other ideas
you know at least play the same thing
but just faster if you know exactly
where the pieces belong um exactly what
the plans are just play slightly faster
and i mean i myself invest way too much
time it's impractical i have such
problems with time management but in
rapid chess the only way to compete
against these guys is to have
uh kind of a bit of extra cushion on the
clock for later in the game we saw that
with mishra when he nearly beat ding and
just the clock
kind of stole that win away from him um
so okay now look at the time i mean eric
hansen we're on move 16. i mean it's a
little little trick here as well dave
doesn't i mean let's say
white's got one bishop he hasn't
developed and i was thinking okay well
why don't you just bring that bishop out
we can maybe show this analysis board
you want to develop all your pieces so
let's say we bring that bishop somewhere
sensible like g5 uh but already now um
black has a bit of a tactical stroke
here i think that works he can you can
go knight takes porn and this is just
undermining white's position and uh you
know if you take that knight of your
queen
black's queen comes down and now you can
see the black queen is very useful and
you've won you've won a very safe pawn
and maybe the game so it's like already
there's some slight problems that eric's
gotta gotta solve here because he's got
one piece let's develop so this is a
weird move but he he he has to do
something to
to get out of this uh well okay i'm
trying to understand it but i'm trying
to understand that
i was thinking maybe he wants to attack
the knights
pawn forward yeah but then it doesn't
quite work either because the black
knight can just simply retreat and too
many pieces are hanging um mystery if
black just makes a move i mean one
that's very common when i study this
type of opening is just to push a pawn
forward just to kind of sit and wait
and yeah what's white's next turn yeah
because you still can't really kick the
knight away because knight takes pawn
even i would have thought some some just
putting up an attack again against this
knight you know and it's the same thing
if you move your rook across to try and
defend this pawn then black can take the
other pawn again
uh distract away this guy and once that
pawn's distracted the defense of the
white knights dropped
um the white queen is not necessarily on
a great square it's only ready to trade
nothing more he played like as you say
david he's two moves on the side of the
board i understand the one the left-hand
side a3 but the move on the other side
near the king this h3 move to me is
completely irrelevant to the position
and it lost a very actually you know it
was just a
lazy move it's one of those moves which
okay probably helps your position but
it's a lot better that you can't really
afford yeah it's like a luxury luxurious
pawn move which doesn't have a great
deal of point may you know i'm not
saying it's about a terrible move but
surely there's something a bit more
point that could have been played there
i don't know i don't know why the
queen's gone back now
struggling to to understand this move
struggling too simon and i think he and
mishra a sign of maturity here would be
just to wait and sit and play on eric's
clock first of all but also just ask
eric what is his next move because here
in the studio we're struggling to find
an idea for white so i would just
suggest maybe pushing this pawn forward
maybe moving the black rook of various
ideas also at some point simon's other
idea of kind of putting the queen in the
corner on that really nice diagonal but
uh just a waiting move and i think it's
really already worrying times for eric
hanson and the chesapeara fan fans out
there yeah it's a battle between the
neighboring countries canada and the us
hanson against mishra also a battle
between neighboring countries sweden and
norway grandelias against magnus carlsen
i mean the bar is roughly to the middle
but apparently magnus is frustrated in
that game giving away a lot of uh
emotions is he struggling um i don't
think magnus is struggling but i looked
over and after only 12 or 13 moves
magnus was completely winning and i
thought that i thought we'd see a result
within a move or two but
and now i look back at the position i
have no idea what's happening is chaos
so magnus has lost control
um maybe just relaxing too soon yeah and
do remember if you are following us on
twitch you can design your own show
using the control center and you can
have up several games if you want to and
for example also then follow grandelias
against magnus carlsen where apparently
magnus is a little frustrated
showing some emotions
prague
the bar is all the way over to his side
in that game against aryan tari
geary all right the bar is liking it
again for him a good day maybe for anish
giri against hari krishna here in round
three and also for shanklin the bar all
the way over to his side against world
number two teng iran that would be an
amazing win for the american but we are
following hansen
mishra can the 13 year old
win
this game that would be an incredible
performance and it seems you're liking
it for him david yeah i mean maybe there
were more active moves available maybe
more accurate moves available but i
think it's a very mature decision just
wait your point is doing nothing
and this rook move does hint at black
starting to push pawns forward in the
center
um the tension is still massive right
now um it's gonna be about who cracks
who cracks first and just the clock
situation says to me that maybe eric is
going to be the first to crack
um white's pawn center looks great but a
lot of responsibility comes with that
white pawn center and
sooner or later there will be threats
against it with a great center comes
great responsibility exactly spider-man
just like mishra's poster and he knows
all about spider-man so like yeah
maybe he has spider maybe he moved
spider-man in front of him so he can see
it yeah
to get that inspiration are you allowed
to dress up as spider-man that would be
it i mean if i was playing in this
tournament i'd probably dress up as
i don't know actually that's a good
question what would we all dress up as
if we have a tournament on halloween for
example
well there's there's a crypt tournament
that we're doing so we're uh
david could be superman
i don't know
you could be uh the riddler in green i
don't know maybe you know like a little
riddle now and again yeah yeah possibly
yeah
yeah yeah well i'll be tinky-winky then
so david can be his true self clark kent
superman yes taking off my hands
purple is my favorite color
yeah and well well the mystery has been
revealed because this was eric hansen's
intention all along it was basically to
this challenge with annie the a pawn and
well it looks a little bit odd though so
his idea is to move all his pieces back
to where they start get ready for the
next game i think that's like okay eric
well that should be a rule put them back
in the box if you're able to put all the
pieces back to the starting square yeah
you start okay to start again yeah
that's clearly what he had planned right
now look at that how many pieces of his
on the first row quite a few yeah i mean
two of eric's last three moves have been
putting his pieces back where they came
from this knight is now back on its
starting square this white queen is back
on the first rank imagine for example if
black just makes a move and white pa
parks his bishop back on the left right
there king king h1 yeah
look at these pieces i mean this is
never ever going to happen but he's
already started that
kind of maneuver so okay um i mean in
the current position if we go back to it
these pieces are just not great for
white
his whole idea eric is for example um
maybe this pawn is attacked so maybe he
def uh mishra defends it but now eric
will start the kickback
potentially by pushing his pawn forward
forcing away the black knight kinking it
back where it came from and now he'll
start bringing his pieces out his bishop
his knight they could start moving and
kind of finally escaping the first rank
mishra meanwhile is more ambitious he
doesn't care about this pawn he's trying
to open up the position and this makes a
lot of sense a lot of logic here if
white's pieces are asleep like this why
not open things up while they aren't
ready
yeah i love it
is there a tactic if white pushes on in
the middle which the move white would
play nearly instantaneously is just to
keep the position closed push that pawn
on but i'm now wondering is mishra
lining up at night takes pawn because
he's done this very crafty move i think
a very mature mover lining up the black
rook against the white queen and this is
certainly the kind of tactic that both
players have to watch out for white
takes the knight with the pawn and of
course now the pawn goes forwards and uh
there's there's some tactical chances
here certainly i don't know if it works
but you've got to calculate it yeah for
example here black is sacrificed a piece
but now he's going to win one of the
pieces back because this is a double
attack a fork if white takes this pawn
for example as simon mentioned this pawn
can step forward and uh here because the
bishop is pinned against the white queen
the bishop will drop uh on the next turn
in the center so eric felt okay that was
too scary and he's allowing the position
to open up slightly he's traded off in
the center and
i think the first move that comes to my
mind is not taking back with the black
pawn because then it is slightly blocked
uh in the center at least temporarily
but instead to take back with a black
knight so now for example okay he does
take with the pawn uh for example now if
he takes with the pieces then suddenly
lines have opened up this rook and queen
have opened up this rook has opened up
and uh if you compare the pieces it's
clear which side has more activity but
okay taking with the pawn
probably still very good for black but
you've got you've got to ask why eric's
put his pieces on the back though now
because they just it just doesn't look
like the right plan for eric here uh i
mean what are the what are they actually
doing there uh at the moment and i think
mishra has played played this incredibly
cleverly but you're right i do prefer
the idea that you just point out david
trying to keep the more open lines
towards
uh white's position yeah and i have to
point out that abby man mishra's idea is
simply that the pawn or that's up for
grabs on b4 isn't really up for grabs
because there is a pawn under fire in
the center so this is why eric just
develops his pieces and well
simon you asked what are his p what are
eric's pieces doing on the first row i
think mikhail tal has the best quote of
all when it comes to that sleeping
sleeping yeah yeah
sleep is good for chess in general but
not for your pieces
just get a good night's a good night of
sleep yourself and
i just want to commend as well mishra's
last move bring the black knight back
when your piece when your opponent's
pieces are cramped
misplaced don't trade them off ever so
eric just brought his knight forward
that night was asleep as ivanka
mentioned offering a trade don't trade
off your opponent's sleeping pieces keep
everything on the board
just because your opponent will be
cramped they have no space and
he did a great job there keeping the
knights on the board now the white
queen's gone back to where she came from
just four or five moves ago
eric has lost so much time not only on
the clock but also on the board you see
that mishra energy again he started
bopping again that young 13 year old
energy it seems to be something he does
when it's looking good it's really
really annoying playing against someone
like that over the board
i think i think ivanka said i used to do
that
when i was mishra's age i was
shaking the table getting very excited
is that right was that did i used to do
that no no no you weren't like you
weren't physically shaking you were just
nodding your head
yeah like yeah
it must be annoying though i didn't mean
yeah you've got to put it somewhere
right when i was his age well actually i
was younger than his age i was always
kicking my opponent under the table
that's not very nice i know i got told
you so many
no it was never on purpose i was just
simply swinging my legs and you know
i could remember this at one time when i
was playing it it was probably like 13
and they were the two players next to me
one one of them actually goes oh can you
can you please stop kicking me under the
table and his opponent just said no
it was like what i was hoping i just
like what a response so you know this
quite nice sort of elderly gentleman you
know was playing like a 30 year old and
the 30 i was obviously kicking him and
he just lit she said oh do you mind stop
kicking me under table no no
it was like okay
i went back to kicking him again it was
just a really weird response you know
wow okay meanwhile a few moves and it
does look like eric's slowly starting to
get organized with his pieces white's
pieces are kind of elevating themselves
off the back rank finally but in the
meantime mishra has relocated to the
black knights
a lot of pressure on white's pawns now
on this left half of the board also
white pawn in the center it is attacked
three times it's tying down white's
pieces okay mishra has to get his queen
out of the way um out of the eye line of
the white rooks and once he's done that
i think eric is a bit stuck
i don't really see any productive plans
for eric
mishra i feel has missed some big
opportunities already though so
yeah the clock situation also look at
this we're in for a massive time
scramble
we're going to see i think most of this
game played out with both sides on 10
seconds
because look at the clock times it's
only moved too who does that favor eric
i have to say you know because this is
uh eric's bread and butter you know he's
played wow
thousands probably millions of bullet
games and you know he instinctively
knows how to activate the pieces and
also how to kind of harass the opponent
with not that much time on the clock
and uh
yeah abimanu
moving his queen just getting out of the
eye line of the white rooks
good move there it's a nice move he
still has a small time advantage it's
not much i want to i kind of
want to give mishra the benefit of the
doubt as well i think if it comes down
to a situation where they both have 30
seconds left if it's pure calculation i
think mishra is maybe
just as sharp as eric but if it's just
kind of general scramble chaos or just
slowly improving the pieces i think eric
has a big edge there
now that they're both so low on time so
i do feel that mishra needs to strike
soon before it's too late before the
chance passes just like it did against
ding in the last round
um i'm struggling to see a move though
for eric meanwhile white's queen can
take a step up one square maybe
david when you were mishra's age
obviously your
highest rated player of all of us here
and you know you've been over 2700 when
you were mishra's age you you kept
improving and one of the problems a lot
of players get is they get to an age
maybe gm whatever you know i am and they
can't improve anymore you know and just
wondering what you did uh to to keep
improving as you did was there anything
particular you did or or did you
remember yeah i i mean i found my
journey especially at misery's age quite
kind of kind of
i don't know the right word for it but
it was a bit up and down i mean i would
often make big jumps and it would take
me a long time to consolidate that kind
of jump and then i would make another
big jump after six months a year or two
i mean i would just work as hard as i
could i'd get in a routine i used to do
a lot of puzzles always analyze annotate
my games immediately afterwards i'd play
as much as possible but
i mean i guess that would be my advice
just play and be disciplined about it
because when you're young it's hard to
keep that discipline that's why the top
young players they have such kind of
good teams around them
yeah the sirens the coaches i mean it's
hard work you have to put in a lot of
hard work all the players here you know
it's not just a magical thing where
they've suddenly become you know top
players in the world you have to
dedicate to to learning uh they say i
think to get good at anything is it ten
ten thousand hours yeah so
you know
that number was kind of plucked out of
the night
[Laughter]
around just 10.
apparently that's just a totally random
number you know they just came up with
it someone should start monitoring yeah
you know even from a very young age
yeah i mean uh i know mishra he spent
thousands of hours i think on chesapeal
alone so imagine that's just accessible
playing as well yeah
i think i've spent tens of thousands of
hours playing bullet chess which is a
waste of it i think one of the problems
nowadays is having that balance between
playing online
and working you know because so many
people just love playing online but
they're never really improving so you've
got to have the balance between both you
know it's fun to play a little bit but
don't forget if you really want to get
better it's much more fun when you're
beating everyone as well so he wants to
do a bit of work anyway it's just
getting a good balance between you know
the sort of work side and play yeah and
how should you balance between working
on openings middle game and the end game
is it equal time physically interesting
you say that because uh during my chess
talks with shakarel majarov you know
which will be released quite soon he
actually gives some advice he goes focus
on the beginning and focus on the end ah
yeah i mean i i think
so many people there openings i think
are over overdone yeah you know you know
90 of all chess books i think plus are
all on the openings yeah so some
ridiculous number and everyone they're
just like oh you know they love their
openings when you go around a lot of
people are taught in the past you go
around to their house
and they have like 100 opening books
they're like
great you've got so many open books and
they're like yeah i've really opened it
you know
they're just there you know but it's
like there are other areas of the game
which are more important maybe even the
ending i think in in russia they always
did it the other way around they they
learned the end game first
to give them a good foundation so i
think it's so important not just to
concentrate on the openings but remember
endings are really important you know
middle games as well so
talking about the chess books things we
always had a running joke when it came
when i was studying law at university it
was like yeah we would just buy all
these law books and we'd learn it by
osmosis just by their presence
they would transmit the information but
i mean there's some nice developments
happening in abimenum mishra's favor and
the position because take a look at that
rook on the third row
it looks very impressive yeah and now
all he needs to do i think to get a big
advantage is to back up his rook black's
rook in the white camp support it with
the other one he's done it very logical
very strong
white knight now jumping towards some
pawns but
it feels like the white pawns are
equally weak white we did uh kind of
skip over white did have to trade off
his light squad bishop for one of
black's knights so now black has the
bishop pair as well and black's light
squad bishop is unchallenged so white
pawns if you look at them a lot of them
are sitting on light squares and those
pawns are all going to drop off
can black take one right now there we go
he does go one pawn up mishra and if
everything else gets traded off black
has two
pawns ready to march forward and win the
game
and uh okay eric wins the pawn in the
center but this pawn is much less
relevant right now
under a minute though
you know this is we saw the game ding i
mean he he got a very nice position
played very well but then when he got
short time he he got tricked is it going
to be the same formula uh in this one
he's done everything right so far we
should say
no kind of uh complaints about his moves
and these two pawns are marching they
are connected after all
the good thing about this position maybe
compared to that ding end game is here
you can kind of play by hand you can
kind of just play by instinct there's
not
at least right now any calculation to be
done
ding that end game was very sharp mishra
just kind of miscalculated one move
and uh yeah it's just the clock the
clock's the only thing that can stop him
i think he's winning on the board
right now mishra the more i look at it
the more i think those two black pawns
the a and b pawns for black can't be
stopped
they will cost white at least a piece
and magnus carlsen he has won his first
game of the chesable masters gaining
three points against nelson grandelius
the swede and pragnanda striking back
after that loss to anish giri in round
two winning game three against aryan
tari and the question will abhimanyu
mishra
win his first game of the tournament
against eric hanson here the clock is
ticking down under 30 seconds now hey i
was going to say big moment white's
knight jumped in attacking the black
queen and attacking the black rook
rather than maybe trade off a set of
rooks checking the white king mishra has
taken off this white knight but now eric
is about to establish a strong past pawn
of his own wow which one yeah so white
pawn now can go and take this black
bishop the black light squared bishop
and that white pawn is only two squares
away from promotion
this might become another pawn race we
saw mishra miscalculate pawn race a bit
earlier today
so will lightning strike twice eric
what's he thinking about just take off
this bishop
why think here there's no point i mean i
guess you can take some other things
does it matter i don't think so don't
think it matters
i guess he's thinking
i mean there's there are a few other
pieces to capture i could also trade
trade works maybe trade the dark square
we're not the trade dollar square bishop
do you think you need to decide on that
now you just take it off it does seem
that when mishra gets a good position he
does he does this energetic bouncing
should we say i'm just thinking if i was
playing and when he started doing this
i'd start getting a bit worried right
yeah
you know the crazy frog
he's getting like excited you know he
knows his position is very good but when
you're young of course it's normal
normal to get excited like this so uh
why is eric not playing the most obvious
move in the position he's also giving
mishra time to think it's not about his
own clock eric we know him he can handle
30 seconds but he's giving mishra time
to calculate right now if instantly he
had just taken back that bishop
uh the white b pawn taking that black
bishop
then mishra would have had to react
instantly and maybe a mistake or two
would have come but now mishra has had
one and a half minutes to think about
this next move but also calculate how
long's everything how long's eric fought
about this movie one nearly two minutes
two minutes two years yeah and that's
okay he plays the most obvious move on
the board i mean two-thirds of his time
you've anchored
david just seems crazy i mean i've done
the same my part myself in the past but
i've hated myself for it it's all about
confidence if eric was confident if he'd
had a good tournament last month in the
oslo esports cup he would have played
that move instantly but uh okay mishra
pushing this pawn okay
okay i was maybe expecting a couple of
other moves but now will we see a trade
of rooks will we see a trade of bishops
there are
so many tactics now so many passports
flying he can't spend you can't spend
another minute and a half on this move
that's for sure he needs to he needs to
move quicker this time eric does and
that's the thing mishra had three or
four sensible options there so why was
eric trying to calculate all of them he
should have waited to see what uh mishra
would choose and i think that's a good
tip for everyone at home if your
opponent has four five moves that look
roughly the same don't spend your move
thinking about all of them just play
your move think first uh kind of play
first think later
unless it's kind of an attack where you
have to calculate every single detail
especially in blitz chess rapid change
and now take a look at the clock
situation eric has just under 20 seconds
do you think this is a deliberate kind
of we also see stop fish the moves
because i think this might be a critical
moment oh
um and okay there's only one can move
for white everything else gives mishra a
big advantage he has to take that black
pawn that has just moved with the white
knight he doesn't doesn't find it he
finds the third best move but mishra now
winning again
sorry ivanka no i mean that was
definitely a critical moment and he's
played it now
some chances i mean you've got to get
rid of those pawns haven't you i mean
look at eric he doesn't like it
yep that white knight can just be
captured black is going to be one piece
up it's all about whether white's fire
advanced pawn is strong enough
is that pawn strong enough to compensate
for a piece though it doesn't feel like
it should be no i don't think so no uh
especially when the
black bit knight and the bishop can
coordinate very well to control the
white pawn advance
but it's going to come down to the time
yeah
17 seconds and of course you know
maybe the queen's you know queen endings
you never know you know there's always
an opportunity for perpetual checks but
this is the type of position where if
mishra had won two minutes he would
never ever lose
yes if white is accurate if white
performs a miracle it's a draw but
nothing more than that but with the
clock situation three results are still
possible okay white's queen jumping in
it does look slightly scary for black
but okay that looks like a good move
yeah just using the black bishop to lock
down that white pawn that wants to push
forward so fred and knight takes pawn
here as well yeah i mean if if black can
win that last pawn it should be pretty
straightforward because that's the one
pawn that eric's going to base some
tricks around that
advanced pawn yeah that black bishop has
taken away the only escape square for
the white king off the first rank and
that's why uh eric's had to take a time
out creating another escape square
can we go for mate now i mean this is
where you probably don't you keep the
safety first approach uh or or you
what's always a good move push in harry
yes so better late than never
the h pawn pushing forward that's just a
move to give the black king more space
to maybe make the white king feel a bit
unstable if that black pawn continues
pushing so multi-purpose looks good
and now the white bishop attacking the
black knight eric shaking his head
yeah he doesn't like it no he hates
losing and especially to younger players
and albemarle mitchell is only 13 years
old
yeah i think you've got to beat them
when they're young you know because when
they get older you don't get another
chance i mean like i've managed to beat
a couple of these guys when they're like
you know when they're very young
including magnus yeah yeah when he was
when he was young and like you know
because later on there's no chance
gotta beat them when they're young and
mitchell he's done again everything
right on the board look at the black
knight and the black bishop they've
completely locked down the advance of
white's sea pawn that far advanced pawn
so now the black queen is free she's
free to do her own thing go after pawns
and this is such a great nice move you
know there's really no way for white to
even think about defending that uh
pawn in the middle of the board
okay white gives a check but doesn't
approve the position black king is going
to step forward and then once again
queen takes pawn is coming and well
those white pawns are going to start
falling off the board two pieces are
better than one and black's two pieces
the knight and bishop just control
everything
this one mishra is about to win yeah
it's uh almost guaranteed at this point
wow eric down to two seconds as well he
needs to move
okay he moves his queen but as ivanka
mentioned one pawn is going to drop the
next pawn will soon drop
and uh yeah it's just a cleaning up job
now for mishra get the hoover out yep
ready to resign eric hanson he just uh
turned uh 30 years old i think abimela
he is
13. he is number 602 in the world
eric hanson number 200 something will
this be a huge win for mishra yeah and
especially you know because he it's his
tournament situation you know it's game
three and you know he wants to win and
last time you know it was a big effort
for him to win one game now definite
improvement and uh well he's been
ruthless right now over the board
nice nice kind of tactic there so
black's bishop grabbed a pawn if that
black bishop was captured on the last go
then white's bishop would have dropped
so rather than just trade off bishops
eric has run away with his piece trying
to push his pawn forward but
it's not going anywhere so we actually
get the same position we had two moves
ago but white has lost a pawn in the
process
um yeah now it's level number of pawns
black sibling has an extra knight
and that's going to win the game the
black queen can go pawn hunting
there we go that's a check
will she grab a pawn on the next guy yep
with some nasty frets maybe as well yeah
why not why not take care of the porn
take care and uh
threaten to
you know jump in with a knife and give a
deadly check now you're pawn and a piece
up so yeah
and white's far advanced pawn is firmly
under the locking key nowhere it's uh no
chance now of uh eric saving this game
no plan simply
but this time i've been monus he handled
his time really well perfectly yep and
look at that he bobs his head he's
trading queens and he wins the game look
at that a celebration from the 13 year
old he wins game three here against eric
hanson